it's the fourth of July Independence Day
so simple question simple big question
what do you love about this country the
United States of America I would say
well there are so many things that I
love about the country on uh
you know the Landscapes and the
waterways and the people Etc but on the
kind of a you know the higher level you
know people argue about whether we're an
exemplary Nation
and the that term has been given a bad
name particularly by the neocons the
actions the neocons in in recent decades
who
have turned that uh that phrase into
kind of a justification
for forcing people to adopt American
systems or values at the barrel of a gun
but my father and Uncle used it in a
very different way and they were very
proud of it I grew up very proud of this
country because we were the exemplary
nation in in uh in the sense that we
were an example of
democracy all over the world when we uh
when we first launched our democracy in
we were the only democracy on Earth and
by the Civil War by 1865 there were six
democracies
today there's probably 190.
and all of them in one way or another
are modeled on on the American
experience and it's kind of
extraordinary because
sort of our our first contact with uh
our first seriousness and contact
uh with the European culture and
continent was in 1608
when John went through came over with
his Puritans in the Sloop Arbella and
Winthrop gave this famous speech where
he said this is going to be a city on a
hill this is going to be an example for
you know all the other nations in the
world and he he warned his fellow
Puritans they were you know sitting at
the this great expanse of land and he
said we can't
um be we can't uh uh be seduced by
the The Lure of real estate or by the
carnal opportunities of this land we
have to take this country as a gift from
God and then turn it into a uh an
example for the rest of the world of of
God's love of God's Will and uh and
wisdom and the and then you know to 200
years later 250 years later
they are a different generation they're
mainly Deus or people who
um had a a belief in God but not so much
a love of particularly religious
cosmologies
you know the framers the Constitution
I believe that we were creating
something that would be replicated
around the world and that it was an
example it was in democracy
there would be this kind of wisdom from
the collective you know that and the
word wisdom means the knowledge of God's
will
and that somehow God would speak through
the collective in a way that um
that he or she could not speak through
you know through totalitarian regimes
and um you know I think that that's
something that even though uh
Winthrop was a white man and a
Protestant that every immigrant group
who came after them kind of adopted that
belief and I know my family when you
know our my family came up all of my
grandparents came over in 1848 during
the Potato Famine
and they saw this country as unique in
history as something that
you know that was uh
that was part of kind of a broader
spiritual Mission and so I I'd say that
from a 30 000 foot level that uh you
know that's I grew up
so proud of this country and believing
that it was the greatest country in the
world and for those reasons well I
immigrated to this country and one of
the things that really embodies America
to me is the ideal of Freedom Hunter
Thompson said freedom is something that
dies unless it's used what does freedom
mean to you to me Freedom does not mean
you know chaos
and it does not mean Anarchy it means
that it it it it has to be accompanied
by restraint if it's going to
live up to its promise
um in self first right what it means the
capacity for human beings to
um to exercise and to
fulfill their their creative energies
unrestrained as much as possible by
government so this point has made is
dies unless it's used I agree with that
yeah I do agree with that and I think
he'd
he was not unique in saying that you
know Thomas Jefferson said that the tree
of Liberty has to be uh had to be
watered with the blood of each
generation and what he meant by that is
that it's it's uh you can't live off we
can't live off The Laurels of the
American Revolution
that you know we had a group we had a
generation where between 25
000 and 70 000 Americans died they gave
their lives they gave their livelihoods
they gave their
status they gave their property and they
put it all on the line to give us our
Bill of Rights and that but those Bill
rights the moment that we sign them
there were forces within our society
um that began trying to chip away at
them and that you know what happens in
that regeneration and it is the
obligation of every generation
to safeguard and protect those freedoms
the blood of each generation you
mentioned your interests your admiration
of Albert Camus of stoicism perhaps your
interest in existentialism
Camus said
I believe in myth of Sisyphus the only
way to deal with a non-free world is to
become so absolutely free that your very
existence is an act of rebellion what do
you think he means by that I suppose the
weather
view the world
um and the way that the stoics did and a
lot of the existentialists was that it
was uh that it was so absurd and that
the uh the the problems and the tasks
that were given just to live a life are
so insurmountable
that the only way that we can kind of um
get back the gods for giving us this you
know this uh this uh impossible task of
of living life
I was to embrace that and to enjoy it
and to do our our best at it I mean to
me I
you know I read camo and then
particularly in the myth of Sisyphus as
a
um as kind of as a parable that uh and
it's the same lesson that I think he
right he writes about in the plague
where we're all given these
insurmountable tasks in our lives but
um that uh by doing our duty by being of
service to others
we can bring meaning to a meaningless
chaos and we can bring order to the
universe and
you know Sisyphus was uh was kind of the
iconic hero of the stoics
and he was a man because he did uh
because he did something good he
delivered a gift to humanity
he angered the gods and they condemned
him to put a rock up the hill every day
and then it would roll down when he got
to the top it would roll down and he'd
spend the night going back down the hill
to collect it and then rolling it back
back up the hill again
and the task was observed it was
insurmountable he could never win
but the last line of that book is one of
the great lines which is uh which is
something to the extent that you know I
can picture Earth says smiling because
Camus belief was that even though he um
his task was insurmountable that he was
a happy man
and he was a happy man because he put
his shoulder to the stone
he took his duty he embraced the tasks
and the you know and the absurdity of
life and he pushed the stone up the hill
and that if we do that and if you know
we find ways of being of service to
others that is you know the ultimate
that's the key to the lock that's the
solution to the puzzle each individual
person in that way can rebel against
absurdity by discovering meaning to this
whole messy thing and we can bring
meaning not only to our own lives but
we can bring meaning to the universe as
well we can bring some kind of order to
life
um
you know that those the Embrace of those
tasks and the and the commitment to
service
resonates out from us to the rest of
humanity in some in some way